Cameron, why don't you try drawing the
critical rendering path diagram for this example?
>> Sure. Let's see. First things first. We
request this HTML. Then we start to build the
DOM and come across this CSS file, which of
course we have to request. We continue to build
the DOM and then immediately encounter app.js, which
is parser blocking. So we halt construction of the
DOM, request, and wait for the file. When we
finally get the CSS and have built the CSSOM,
we can run app.js and then continue to build the DOM. And then we hit
the next script, timing.js, so we block
parsing on the download. Does that sound right?
>> Yep, that's right. However, this could take quite a while. First
we block on app.js and wait for it to arrive. Then on
timing.js, and wait for that to arrive. To optimize this particular case,
the browser has a special process called a preload scanner, which peaks
ahead in the document, and tries to
discover critical CSS and JavaScript files, like timing.js.
>> Well that's clever, so even though the parser is
blocked, we can discover timing.js
and initiate downloads for critical resources?
>> Yeah, exactly, so instead of waiting to build
the CSS object model, and run app.js before requesting.
>> timing.js. The preload scanner finds timing.js and requests it while the
parser is blocked.
>> Cool. Well, that's pretty interesting. Where
can I learn more about the preload scanner?
>> Check out the instructor notes. You'll find a couple of good resources
there that will help explain why the preload scanner exists and how it operates.